[Applaudissements]
parler à la famille et puis papa il m'a
dit écoute mon amour pourquoi pas est ce
que toi tu es allé si toi tu es mal à
l'aise ça va se voir ça sera pas beau ça
sera un échec
sinon je crois que je peux le faire
alors on a choisi une photographe
exceptionnelle qui hélène renault qui
est une femme qui vous met en confiance
complètement alors évidemment ce que
pour éviter de montrer juste mes fesses
parce que la photo il essaie une double
bras je montre pas juste mais j'étais ça
il était j'étais là ça va il faut monter
il ya malicieux va regarder tonnes dans
l'avion des années que je l ai choisi
quatre un fauteuil à la couverture et 3
à long terme y en avait un peu plus vrai
alors justement quels sont les autres
[Applaudissements]
il y en avait d'autres un peu plus
habillée oui et avec l'achat avec la
chemise de nuit en avait une qui était
vraiment que moi je trouvais très
poétique avec la chemise de nuit
une autre encore dans une position que
je trouvais très bel et bon forcément si
le principe c'est comme une des
magazines ça reste les magazines je
pense qu'il faut pas se voiler la face
ces principes c'était de nous montrer nu
ils ont choisi plutôt les photos j'étais
assez normal j'étais plutôt visible je
ne cache pas que vous avez donné des
idées passent